Okay, for this section of liquidity, we're going to be looking at the main
areas of liquidity
and how I've basically enforced liquidity. You can see I've gone back in time a
little bit here.
The liquidity indicators and have a future where you can see all of the
previous levels of liquidity
because it will just make your charts a nightmare. So we only really care about
current moment
relative liquidity, plain and simply, but there are there are main features of
liquidity.
So people don't understand this, but liquidity is everywhere. People have this
idea that liquidity
is this magic pill in the market. It's not liquidity is literally just money
and money in the markets
are everywhere. However, there are areas where there are more concentrated
levels of liquidity
than others. For example, there is a lack of liquidity in it in an imbalanced
level like this,
but an abundance of liquidity at a high like this. And that's all it is. And so
like a magnet to
metal, price likes to gravitate towards key areas of liquidity. And so I could
have built
this indicator and put every little equal low and equal high, but the reality
is, is they're
everywhere. And if you try to avoid every layer of liquidity to make the
perfect trading setup,
then you would never take the trade because liquidity is everywhere. The key
for me and the
liquidity that I use, again, this indicator is for me. I want to use the macro
context liquidity.
I'm not an idiot. I can clearly see when there are a pair of equal lows at a
price point,
and I can probably assume and adjust that there are some level of liquidity in
there. But is it
important not really to be quite frank with you? The main liquidity areas,
which most people miss,
are these ones, previous days high and previous days low, previous weeks high
and previous weeks
low, session highs and session lows. You could also argue pre-open, high pre-
open low, but for
now we won't add that. So session lows and highs and days highs and lows and
weeks highs and lows.
And so when your framings trade ideas, it's really cool to be able to trade
toward levels. So if we
look at EUR/USD in this instance, right, from a higher time frame perspective,
you can see that
we're quite bearish. You can see that previous weeks high is all the way up
here and previous
weeks low is all the way up here. So we open in, right, we're opening price and
for the new week,
right, most likely we're expecting lower prices. If I, if I pull up in here,
for example, the dashboard,
it's likely that it will be bearish from a higher time frame perspective. The
daily
is expected to be bearish. So we're expecting lower prices. The overall
high time frame structure, like a H4, it's also bearish. Now, the thing is, is
what we don't want
to do is, depending on are you a swing trader, are you an intraday trader, are
you a scalper?
Liquidity different liquidity levels will mean different things to you.
And so for instance, we'll, we'll just see how price reacts to liquidity levels
and kind of some
instant, some insight on what I would say. So if you have a previous day's high
in here and we're
opening pretty close to that previous day's high, the reality is, is we're
going to go and
collect liquidity from that previous day's high. It's most likely that we're
going to
go collect the liquidity from that previous day's high. And if we're trending
in a downward move,
then a previous day's low is a great target to expect price to hit. An Asian
low, as we've already
walked through a little bit with the session boxes, is a great target to hit.
So if you play
price out, you can see price sweeps previous day's high and runs and expands
above it,
because it's going to, it's going to collect and capture liquidity from that
level. And then
you see we have London's high. We're going to capture liquidity from those
levels. And then you
can see that we have this movement that's reversal and this move lower, even if
I was to toggle the
structure, for example, should be a change of character in here. Yes. So the M
15 was bullish.
We have a higher time frame directional bias as bearish. We have previous day's
low, previous
week's low, that these are clear magnets of liquidity. We had previous days
high, we breached
previous days high, which is the first thing you want to be looking for in a
bearish move.
If price is going to move bearish, let's say this is a candle, right? And you
have a new candle
opening in here. If we're going to have a bearish move, usually what happens is
price will run first
toward buy side, collect liquidity, and then expand towards our side, which is
why if you look at
bearish candles, they usually have a wick on the top. Because we open, we run
higher,
and then we usually run lower. We open, we run higher, and then we usually run
lower.
And so it's the same thing in the macro as it is in the macro.
The likelihood is is that we're going to run higher and then run lower, but we
still can't
just paste up of that. Then we have the structure, we change character. So a
literal perfect trade
idea would be to go short in here at this fair bar. You go covering the high
and taken out previous
days low and previous weeks low for context, because price is going to draw
from liquidity
levels to liquidity level. But again, you have to have the context, you have to
have the high
time from narrative, you can't just wait for a previous days high to get taken
and just start
trading short previous days low. It's like, no, you have to have the context of
understanding price.
But again, just price is going to gravitate toward those levels. Again, there's
obviously
liquidity set below these levels. I don't need that to draw an indicator to see
that.
You can see we take out London's low liquidity, and we can even run all sweet
liquidity.
So now you'll know, this is the, this is an old daily low. All right, that
still didn't get run.
Now we have previous days high up in here, and now we have previous days low.
The market's closed,
right? This is previous days low. Do you really think that price is going to
come all the way
to this previous days high, take it to go all the way to this previous days low
? No, of course,
it's not because we've already created the highs in here. We might come and
take an Asia session high
and then go. But that's how we primarily use an liquidity. You see, we just
straight out take
out previous days low, we take out the low before that look at that type of
move. That's a liquidity
run. And we're probably going to be targeting toward previous weeks low, most
likely, because
that was the bias for the week. But we'll see, maybe we don't. It's an
important part of why
we take profits as well. So, okay, we'll just keep playing price. So you can
see,
I have Asia high in here. Okay, now, now the day's opened. And so you have
previous days low in here,
previous days lower down here, previous days high up here.
London high that gets taken, London low that gets taken. And again, you can
just see
price wants to gravitate toward liquidity levels. And again, this is more of
obviously a
swing trade, as opposed to the typical trade in the IAM involved in, which is
primarily based off of
intraday. But again, you can literally frame entire trades just based off of
liquidity with
a little bit of structure, and a little bit of fat value gaps, because price
will want to
gravitate toward liquidity. But we can literally keep playing it. Now, we've
taken previous week's
high, previous week's low, previous week's low has been taken. Again, you're
seeing how
price is able to react to liquidity in real time, because these are the areas
of liquidity that
mean the most. Now, you see, we have previous days high on the high part, and
price seeks it
immediately. London low and London highs, these are going to be your key levels
of liquidity,
right? And notice how price doesn't take out that previous week's high. That's
why I'm saying
everything is about context. So we have previous days low all the way down here
,
a previous week's high, but now obviously we're in May. Now, we have previous
days high and
previous weeks high up here, we have previous days lower down here. Where do
you think price
is going to want to gravitate to? It's literally a perfect target. And again,
look.
And so liquidity for me is more so a place to take profits is one of the
biggest things for
liquidity. And other one is identify areas that you would like to see traded
through first before
we get the move that we're looking for. And so whilst liquidity isn't the
context builder,
it still gives, it still does provide some level of context to what it is that
we're doing.
And I could do this like, I could just literally close this, pull price back to
just a completely
random area of price. What day is it? It's a Tuesday. Here's a Monday. Here's
previous week's high.
Again, you can see here that the higher timeframe, the weekly in this instance
is anticipating higher prices. I mean, it doesn't take a genius to see that we
are
overall trending higher from the macro. Now, our small 15 minute structure
levels,
that's intraday. The overall general consensus of higher prices is trading
toward the buy side.
Cool. So now we have London low down here, London high and London low down here
as well.
And the price takes none of the low side but gravitate straight toward the buy
side. Previous
days high and previous days, previous weeks high as well. Well, now that
objective has been complete.
What other liquidity do we have to go into the next day?
Previous days high, it gets taken immediately. New York lowest got stacked
liquidity on it.
It's taken and it's intelligent too. So that when you hit the level,
it stops at the level it's hit. So you don't just have extended lines on your
child all times.
So again, look what it is, something as a context provider. So we have, okay,
here's a great example.
So we're bullish overall. Asia low down here, Asia high up here. Previous days
high previous days low.
For me personally, this is like the perfect higher time frame take profit.
I don't have a don't really know what's going on in the scheme of things. I can
see with bullish,
I can see on the 15 minute timeframe, we are also bullish. So realistically,
this is
a where you would want to see price kind of gravitate to. You can see here,
Asia low gets taken out.
And we run perfectly toward previous weeks high. And so this is how, if
anything, I would be using
liquidity to frame not necessarily just trade ideas, but also just
understanding the narrative.
And sometimes it's not super clean. And sometimes it's super clean. That's for
you to develop in
yourself, understand that when is something just so obvious, we are daily,
weekly directional
bias bullish m15 with bullish. Previous days high is sitting on this level.
Previous weeks high
has already been run. Now we're in continuation phase. And so the only the only
relevant liquidity
here is previous days high. Asia session high is already taken. So it's not
really important.
So if I'm framing a trade set up, if I'm a London trader or a New York trader,
what I would
realistically like to see is a run out of the importance of the sell side
liquidity.
And then some type of acceptance battle between supply and demand,
a outcome from demand show meeting control and previous days high is my go to.
That's
that's my target. Something like this, where you're running out, but we fail to
trade higher. So it's
not on yet. Okay, now we're starting to accept lower prices. Now we run out.
Now's the time to be
looking for a long position after you get the acceptance in the reversal. Right
, you can see
quite clearly, here's the acceptance. This is the move. This is your level.
And this is basically just a combination of structural liquidity, but this is
more of a
15 minute timeframe, somewhat of a swing trading set up, perhaps maybe day
trade. And so you look
at it. But then that's it. That that's your area to gravitate towards. So if
you were bearish on
this day, for example, right, or you're looking at this, let's say, I don't
know, you have a random
strategy, maybe you don't even follow my strategies. That's also fine. But
maybe you look at this as
an area of resistance, right? And you see prices heavily selling off. This is
where you use
liquidity as an avoidance, like do you really think it's wise to take a trade
like this, for example,
account, a trend trade, or whatever you see it, a resistance trade, a failed
breakout. I don't
know, a break back in and retest. I don't know. However, you see the markets, I
'm assuming most
of you guys are beyond those types of concepts, but maybe not. That's also fine
. You can still
be profitable with them. But adding liquidity as a context provider, we are
everything indication
of bullish. Where's price going to target? Where's price? Like there's a magnet
above this price
level, literally pulling price up towards it. And so just use it as a context
provider. Yeah,
you're in great. Everything starts looking well. Okay, we're back in. Price is
chopping around.
Boom. Look at how price hits that level. The entire time price was gravitated
towards here,
and the longer that price spends reloading these levels, the more liquidity
that's being built
above these highs. And so liquidity is really a context provider. And those are
the main kind of
types of liquidity that I am fond of, but liquidity in of itself is not
something that you can just
rely on. It has to be used in combination and in tandem with everything else.